Well remember that we have 20, um,
conversion therapy laws that prohibit them from doing anything other than
affirming, because that might be considered, you know,
the so-called conversion therapy might be trying to convert them out of being
trans. Now, in essence, they could lose their license,
they could lose their license. Um, now of course, conversion therapy,
the reason we pass these bands was to,
it was to eliminate the really ugly practices of gay conversion
therapy. That's how they got past,
but they inserted activists inserted gender identity language.
So now a therapist can't even say to a child, hold on.
I know you say you're a boy,
but let's explore some of the other things that seem to be upsetting you.
Are you worried that the slippery slope of this ultimately is that, you know,
a child will, uh, a girl,
young girl will basically announced that she's trans at school,
a parent or the parents will say, well,
we're not transitioning to something like that. And then as the state grows,
and again,
we're both in California that literally the state will start taking kids away
from their parents. Like, is that something that,
that you think is really legit.
It's already happening? I mean,
you especially hear that now we're where with divorce,
divorce couples where they're not on the same page D I I've had,
I've been called by a mother who was, you know, she was divorced,
but she had full custody of the daughter because the court deemed her the more
responsible, better parent. And when the daughter hit 13 out of nowhere,
she decided she was trans with the encouragement of her therapist and,
and her step-mom. And the moment the mom said,
the mom put the brakes on it and said, honey, you don't look. You know? And,
and the mom was not gender conforming herself. The mom said, honey, look,
you're, you're still a girl just because you'll, you know,
you don't want to dress girly. That's fine. Um, then, then the,
um, a social worker was brought in and decided that, um,
the mom was no longer a safe parent.
God. I mean, it's just, it's, it's, it's twisted. It's deeply twisted.
What about on the parent's side where we've seen some stories like this,
I can think of one from about two months ago.
We're really seems to be the parent that's driving this,
that the stuff we talked about earlier about, Oh,
you suddenly are getting a lot of likes on tumbler or you're feeling like you're
in a group suddenly that we've heard some instances where it seems like the
parents are the ones driving their children towards this,
because then they sort of by proxy feel popular or liked, or,
or as an oppressed screw, they're,
they're an oppressed group adjacent or something.
Right. So I think that does happen. Um,
the population I really looked at is the biggest population.
It's this teen girl population and the, and, and there, you don't, you know,
these are young women who aren't listening to mom at all. In fact,
the last thing they want is advice from mom. And so usually in that instance,
the parents aren't so much the driver sometimes with the little kids,
you do see parents who they, you know,
who seem to be pushing this awfully hard and certain certainly seem to be
bragging about it online in ways that make you wonder if they aren't getting
something else out of it.
Yeah. All right. The shrinks are up next.
I know that you're not thrilled with the way therapists have dealt with it.
Yeah. I mean, they have an affirmative model right now, the majority,
although I interviewed, look,
I interviewed a lot of giants in the field who don't agree with it and are not
affirmative therapist,
but affirmative therapy says we start from the conclusion.
We know that we're going to agree with that,
that a young person who says they're gender dysphoric,
we're going to agree that that's the right diagnosis.
We'll affirm them as transgender.
And the only question is when do we get started on the medications? And, um,
you know, that's, that's just not medicine.
Medicine is an evaluation of risks and benefits.
And the moment you are open about the risks and benefits of any medical
treatment, you're, you're not in the gender affirmative camp anymore. You're,
you're on my side of things, which is to have an open look and,
and approach with some skepticism,
how these girls are and whether they're benefiting.
Do you sense that the,
that some of the psychologist or the psychiatrist that they're actually not
telling these young girls, the,
what the numbers are in terms of either regretting it later in life or that it's
not going to solve all of your problems or, or that suicides are still high?
I mean, all of these things that are uncomfortable to talk about, I mean,
do you sense that they kind of hide that because they're, they're just on board?
Well, remember that we have 20, um,
conversion therapy laws that prohibit them from doing anything other than
affirming, because that might be considered, you know,
the so-called conversion therapy might be trying to convert them out of being
trans. Now in essence, they can lose their license,
they could lose their license. Um, now of course, conversion therapy,
the reason we pass these bands was to,
it was to eliminate the really ugly practices of gay conversion
therapy. That's how they got past,
but they inserted activists inserted gender identity language.
So now a therapist can't even say to a child, hold on,
I know you say you're a boy,
but let's explore some of the other things that seem to be upsetting you. Yeah.
Can you clean that up a little bit for people that have nothing,
no knowledge of any of this, the sort of difference between sexual identity,
meaning your sexuality versus verse gender identity and why conversion
in each case or conversion therapy in these cases,
it's not exactly apples to apples.
Sure. So with homosexuality, you know, um, we we've, we, you know,
we've long known that this is seems to be innate and immutable.
It's not the kind of thing you can sort of convert someone out of or convince
them out of. And nor should you want to. I mean, this is,
there's nothing unhealthy about a gay life. There just isn't.
But when you're talking about, um, you know,
the letting a child become comfortable in their own body,
because gender identity, if a young woman suddenly says, I'm really a boy out,
I need to become a boy.
You're setting them up to be a lifetime medical patient where they will put
testosterone in their bodies. They need to stay on it for life.
It has all kinds of terribly extreme side effects.
They're are highly risky. Um, and unlike, you know,
therapy that may make her comfortable in her body,
the today's therapy pushes her to transition. Um,
that's very different from,
from being gay in which all the gay person asks is that you accept them for what
you, what they are. What, what, uh, you know, what a trans teen asks is you,
can you help me try to be what I'm not?
And that's a much more invasive intervention.
Yeah. You know, I'm reminded as you're talking about this,
I I'm blanking on whether you mentioned the show in the book.
Did you talk about transparent at all the show?
So in there's a line in the last episode of the first season
where a woman who's already transitioned says to the main character,
who's about to begin the process in effect, this is going to ruin your life.
This is going to ruin your family.
And that in many ways is what the show ended up being about.
And I know that's not about a child transitioning,
but I think a lot of what you're talking about is just that so many people just
don't have a holistic view of what this is going to be like on the other side.
That's exactly right.
And when I interview transgender adults who are very happy in their transitions,
very often, they will still tell me, look, this is not easy.
It's not easy to go through life on all this hormonal treatment, you know,
holding yourself out as a member of the opposite sex. It's really hard.
And when, when transgender adults talk to me about it,
they are horrified that teenagers are getting this. So this,
this hormonal treatments so easily,
without any kind of understanding of the risks and, you know,
and not appreciating how hard medical transition really is.
So all that being said, chapter seven is about the dissidents. There,
there are some dissidents in the field.
That's right. A number of prominent people have stood out and said, hold on.
This is way too much, way too fast with too little medical oversight. Um,
you know, look, the court found, you know, and I, I interviewed a lot of them,
including, you know, Ken Zucker who chaired the entry, the,
the writing of the entry on gender dysphoria for the DSM five,
the classic psychiatric manual on, uh, on mental disorders. And,
um, you know, these are people who say,
starting with the conclusion is not medicine, right? And in fact,
last week, um, a,
the British high court examined the same protocols that they have in place in
Britain for gender medicine. And the, the high court was appalled. They said,
you know,
in effect what's been going on here is likely to transition a lot of young women
who are not supposed to be transgender. And a lot of, you know,
young people who are likely experience severe.
Regret,
looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about women's issues
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our women's issues playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.